you're never going to have true equality
it's like me personally but I'm saying
that I'm saying we shouldn't I don't
care about male I'm saying we shouldn't
have to say no I'm saying we shouldn't
fight for True equality because people
want to do different things in different
groups and I'm saying in the top one
percent I've seen what it takes to get
there I've seen firsthand I've seen my
dad like grow up he he worked 60 70
hours a week he didn't have a life he
didn't have friends most women Valley
like we value a social life we value
having fun like what I've had to do the
last three years to build this like just
most girls would not do it oh no not at
all oh no and that's okay but that
doesn't mean women are being
discriminated against it means they
don't want to work 60 70 hours a week